[Music]
this is a new segment that I call
popular songs some unpopular styles she
had them bottom jeans and the boots with
the fur
Oh who's looking at her she hit the
floor next thing you know shorty got low
shorty got blue
baggy sweatpants and the Reeboks with
the straps
turn around I get that big booty is
smack yeah get the floor next thing you
know straight low sure yeah
but that's only one of the things that I
wanted to do today I also want to show
you something that I found that I
haven't shown you yet that I should have
shown you a long time ago this my
friends is the contents of the try tube
side down right let's put in the year
1000 leaf X and build his house this is
actually a rubbing done by secret mother
x rubbed in every green color from
Crayola 64 pack asparagus robin's egg
Granny Smith see green forest green at
federer etc etc also I wanted everybody
to see their says PS your Miffy for
brother hahaha
I would also like to announce the end of
the first boarding book club barbed fest
it was really hard to try and find all
the blog post that had blurbs in them so
I'm sorry if I missed you but most of
them are catalogued at nerdfighters comm
and three blog posts just below this
video and I'm asking everybody to read
through those and then go to the forums
and list your favorites so that we can
figure out who's the best to who's gonna
get the prize so I'm changing the rules
for the second learning book up a little
bit because it was so hard to find
everybody's blurbs instead of posting a
blog post there's a specific topic in
the forum where you can post your blurbs
don't both anything besides blurbs in
there so we can keep it all straight
post your blurbs and maybe a little bit
of a description about your blurb if you
want but no like discussion back and
forth or else it'll just get it's
confusing as the blog posts work also I
want to emphasize only one blurb per
person and ten words per blurb anything
more than that I'm not gonna be angry at
you but I'm also not gonna include you
in the contest sorry new blurbing book
club book if you're curious is
slaughterhouse-five there's a link to
buy it over in the sidebar or you can
get it at any bookstore in the world
probably it's also really easy book to
find used so if you have a used
bookstore nearby she can get you check
it out
Laboral are great I'm a big fan of this
lolcat one mini minute minute many of
them are awesome and it's going to be
hard to choose so but hopefully you guys
can help me with that I would also like
to announce that in honor of our twenty
thousand subscriber who I can't figure
out who it is because there's too many
and I think counting isn't working
anymore not the way I used to do it in
honor of them I and possibly John are
going to be available for a video chat
via stickum which you can find at
nerdfighters calm the chat will be on
the front page of nerdfighters calm at
precisely 7 o'clock mountain time 6
o'clock Pacific and then o'clock Eastern
and I have no idea if you're outside the
US what time it's gonna be but you can
figure it out it's 7 o'clock
Mountain Standard Time maybe I'll twenty
thousand of our subscribers will come
probably not
mean seriously twenty thousand
subscribers that is
at all for today I'm looking forward to
seeing all of you tomorrow night
actually I'm looking forward to having
all of you see me tomorrow night you
will mostly just be names it may be a
little busy in there I'm gonna do my
best
John maybe I'll see you tomorrow but I
can't get you on the phone so